what's up guys it is jerry um
just figured i'd pop in here really
quick to uh talk to you guys about a
movie i saw last night
the new hayao miyazaki film uh the wind
rises
this was the first miyazaki film i've
seen in a long time actually
i think the only other one i've seen is
princess mononoke
which i quite enjoyed back in the day
and i should probably revisit it i went
to see this last night
i was treated to a screening and um
it's a gorgeous film uh it it really is
um we saw it
um in the original japanese with
subtitles um
the american dubbed version has a lot of
really great
actors uh lending their voices to it i
think joseph gordon-levitt
elizabeth banks william h macey vernon
herzog
a bunch of people yeah this is the first
miyazaki film i've seen in a while and
from what i've heard it's very different
uh from a lot of his works um it's
not a fantasy really i mean there are
certain
fantastical elements here and there uh
as
dreams play a reasonably prominent role
but um it's much more grounded in
reality it's a period piece
uh and it's interesting to get uh that
perspective of the 1930s
and the second world war um
from the other side you know because
japan was not
an ally of ours you know during that
time and it's not
like about the war and it's not
um in your face necessarily but it is
sort of it does take place
in society where it's a reality
you know and it's interesting to see
what the rest of the world was doing and
and
feeling you know at that time this movie
is about
sort of a a young and an aspiring
engineer who really wants to build
airplanes
and the style of the movie sort of
struck me kind of like being like a new
wave almost
um in the sense that it's it's not in
your face with you know
you know plot turn after plot turn it's
very much sort of fly on the wall
so to speak i mean it's animation sort
of watching uh scenarios unfold and
watching life happen
um as depicted by this you know
gorgeous art i mean it's a very lyrical
and poetic movie
in a lot of ways and it has that sort of
life and somewhat
melancholic but still beautiful essence
that a lot of those new wave
movies had and it you know sort of goes
until it it reaches a a place where it
seems appropriate to trail off
um but it's just so gorgeous to look at
there's a lot of really varied art
um and from what i've heard again about
this particular film is the art is also
a departure from his older stuff
in the sense that to me it struck me as
being a lot more impressionistic
there are a lot of um backgrounds and
things that almost look like oil
paintings or watercolor paintings in
some places
the animation feels older it's not quite
as you know
modern and from the little i know about
the process of animation it almost
looked like it was authentically hand
drawn
just from the jitters things would have
um
in certain shots you know where people
would have drawn frames
ever so slightly differently the film
has a very sort of multicultural flavor
to it definitely a lot of it takes place
in japan
but um over the course of the story uh
jiro the the main character does visit a
number of
uh other places you know germany and and
some other parts of europe um and the
music especially accentuates this
a lot of the music feels sort of french
or or italian
um and actually shiro's sort of
inspiration and and his hero is an
italian aeronautical engineer
um so there is sort of a multicultural
quality
to this and which which kind of further
at least for me
sort of reminded me of those old new way
films in the 60s
but um it's a gorgeous film it's it's
a it's wonderful to behold um if you can
see it
i'd say definitely check it out um you i
can't imagine you'd be disappointed it's
not a really out there fantasy or
anything like that
um it's certainly a departure uh but it
is
you know it's an opus uh and it's
definitely worth checking out if you're
a movie fan in general like i don't
think that this is
the type of thing you have to be into
anime
to enjoy so uh yeah that's that's my two
cents
um i'm interested to hear what you guys
thought about the movie if you have
uh seen it and uh what uh what's your
favorite miyazaki film
you know this is a a filmmaker i
definitely want to
you know learn more about and uh
whose work i you know i want to check
out more of
so um yeah go see it man
uh hi omiyazaki the wind rises and i
will catch you guys later
cheers